oh okay the going round I'm shiny look
at the bling around your neck you look
rich how's it gonna be here on the line
name is great you know to see Tommy
company Roni though so you know the boy
is in well they give up the Oscar so did
we okay it's a big it's a big night for
music tonight and Mark Anthony is
receiving an iconic award tonight the
first time they're giving it away why do
you think Mike Anthony deserves it he
does everything bro because you know
he's been in the game for more than 2530
years I see the struggle since its
beginning in New York you know Puerto
Rico knock on door on table and polo and
pull up and pull up bar and taken awhile
and you know I grew up listening
tomorrow so my mom you know every Sunday
he'll appear to you like a song que yo
sabe he simply is always on point you
know every here always on point fashion
wise music wise career wise business
wise so I get Liza all around I gotta
say congratulations on your Latin Grammy
nomination that's right what did that
mean to you when you woke up to that
news means a lot to me you know cuz my
mom before she passed away ten years ago
of cancer she always told me Bobby
see you songyang go see ya trabajando so
you get in then deal just like this deja
vu you know I have to ask you though
obviously after the nominations were out
there were a lot of they get thrown
artists who felt like they were a little
shut out of the big categories you know
what was your feeling on that you know I
think only a young with time I
understand I understand the situation
but you know at um proceso because you
know we just say the same thing happen
with hip-hop and the
early 90s so you know papasano Zadro
pero si Italia no Paso where I came home
okay trabajar meruna no ma so next year
no bueno - yo neck anomalies mo
excellent although congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]